pour pour ce nouveau stream du jeudi
alors j'ai mis ce crime détente
aujourd'hui normalement fabien va
bientôt arriver
on va laisser venir petit à petit mais
ce crime détente qu'on va commencer par
un petit mule est allé fait longtemps
que j'ai plus fait de bull est
d'ailleurs je sais qu'il ya les arénas
bullet qui sont en prépa alors j'ai
appelé femmes allez y faites qui
arrivait au savoir mais je suis déjà en
train de faire un bullet man alive et
ouais ouais je suis déjà je suis en
train de tuer en train de victimiser un
grand matelas enfin le victimise rien du
tout mais j'essaye de victimiser je me
calme ouais mais ta came je fais pas la
rajouter de suite ce que j'essaye de
victimiser la collectivité qui part
toujours l'ex-roi ouais mais tranquille
tranquille vous tranquille où là pour le
moment un pop up mon petit monsieur
hop hop hop je vais je vais ramener mes
pions sur sur les droits fab five c'est
chaud fab c'est chaud je sais pas quoi
jouer belge a pas d'opposition je suis
pas arrivé
non mais des fonds se veut quoi attends
je vais sacrifier une pièce à main se
peut pas bon ben je vais faire un échec
écoute j'ai fait un échec j'ai remplacé
mon fou je me sens un peu longue
brouillard d tu vois là allez je vais
faire un truc un peu chaud
mince je fais de la merde femme chez mr
diadème projet 3 en plus il avait vu
passé horrible je prends une tactique
que j'avais vu ça m'énerve ça quand ça
arrive se prendre quelque chose que tu
vois on est sur l'autoroute je ne suis
pas comme dames 1 ouais mais je crois
qu'ils ont changé d adresse à tanger
perdu après reparti je te mets la
capture le partage à wil dont je
t'adresse soul se cache non tu trouves
je pense et de chasse comme tv
maintenant battant je t'ai mis ça mais
j'étais pas mis le partage tout de suite
que le partage en fait ça me fait bugger
si je fais des bullet je vais jouer re
je vais lag bon mais peu accablant
l'armée là car oui mais le partage non
jusqu'au mais c'est quoi l'adresse je
comprends pas ça doit être chaise com/fr
direct tous comme f1 ouais ouais
jusqu'à mes affaires en grand un enfant
body quoi bon parler d'eux parce que tu
veux mais c'est une meilleure adresse du
coup enfin moi je préfère c'est plus
facile à écrire en fait vendu conduite
parce que les gens connaissent pas
forcément
non non non dwyer marque pas je sais pas
comment ça je peux pas te dire mais je
pense pas à tuer mais non mais tu reçois
les notifications par mail pareil
bonjour a reçu ses abonnés bon alors
voilà je sais ce n'est pas abonnée était
pas bonne est enfin prête à recevoir les
motifs lie mais ce n'est pas abonnée ah
bah oui ta bonne mais ça fait beaucoup
de vues en replay sur youtube sur
surtout la vidéo que j'ai faite
pédagogique le truc pédagogique les gens
beaucoup aimé ouais mais bon je veux
faire de la pédagogie aux échecs à 4,6
il faut faire du pédagogique aux déchets
cacahouète non mais aussi concerts un
truc pédagogique dernière fois sa
rencontre un énorme succès en terme de
like et où j'ai vu la différence les
mecs étaient super heureux bon sinon tu
es chaud pour le chou tu ton flottille
de la demi finale de l'om absolument
rien à faire honnêtement quand même ton
club de coeur
oui mais tu vois le truc c'est que bon
je n'ai pas de parts dans ce club en
gros si gagne ça ne change rien à ma vie
quoi non mais tu as tu des parts where
c'était mais je m'en fous aussi
généralement quand j'ai l'air du rugby
je vais enfin gêné par oui pour les
matches de rugby ces départs soit
quelque part est faut faire très
attention quand je l'attendais du rugby
quoi bizarrement tu vois le résultat
peut influer du coup tu pourras avoir
des parts sur le web aussi le problème
c'est que s'il ya départ j'aurais départ
sur salzburg eux ça devient taquin tu
vas donc du coup on prend des parts chez
son poids et sa longue blessure
non mais en fait j'ai un peu de partir
sur marseille a quand même se dire la
vérité
en fait il pas rond départ sur sa sur
marseille départ sur mitroglou ce qui
fait pas mal oui mais bon il va mieux là
bas oui bah je sais et du coup en fait
je m'en fiche du résultat mais je suis
pour un but de mitroglou quoi je suis
très très chaud pour le but de mitroglou
est ce qu'il ya un pari me trouble ou
pas salzbourg
non mais
j'ai mitroglou marqué marseille gagne
bon écoute on verra bien mais le match
m'intéresse patiente jusqu'à vlad qui
doit venir
alors on ne sait pas là en plus ça va et
qui doit placer normal mais je le foot
même quand j'ai départ je regarde pas
vraiment pas cher faut le savoir
ouais le français est vrai que le france
à l'om de l'est via le coupe d'europe ce
n'est pas tous les jours je démarre sur
arsenal aussi ce match de play off
ou alors la partie est pas mal on
pourrait éventuellement éventuellement
mais toi tu pars demain en bas je peux
pas faire mais oui c'est intéressant
parce que toi tu as plus internet n'aura
pris au maroc ça j'en sais rien mais ça
m'étonne expérience parlant là en plus
apte et dans un bled paumé dans un but
bien bien bien bien bien beau mais paris
ne peux pas avoir internet est pas
possible
sita internet tout est là maintenant je
comprends plus rien à la ville en fête
oui mais ce que tu peux jouer
bon après truc je gardais doubleront dé
toute façon ça va pas être de tout repos
il ya beaucoup doubleront dans ce temps
là voilà beau jeu c'est plus on va tout
mais oui il y en aura sûrement en train
de faire tellement n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui ça me va mais tu crées des
clous m je pense que l'esprit olympiens
de marabouts août non mais je sens que
je vois pas grand chose bonjour les
maqams du coup c'est vrai que je défends
ce n'est que ma connexion pour m
pourquoi on te voyais là elle vous voyez
je leur mets alors je crois que tu étais
pas mis en fait travail si je disais
c'est le partage d'écran que je peux pas
te mettre un vous plus âgés coûte à
moitié je suis en train de gagner une
partie mais je ne sais même pas pourquoi
ni comment en fait je crois avoir fait
absolument rien vu de la partie j'ai
battu un mec 2006 sur de chasse comme
j'ai pas compris honnêtement honnêtement
j'ai pas compris
tu as mais moi ça me choque pas je leur
joue du coup un fab des excuses à
monsieur venir voir la partie tu peux
faire les parties c'est fin c'est pas du
haut niveau 1 c'est horrible
j'ai l'impression d'avoir le cerveau est
en bouillie et de ne rien voir mais je
mens pas car ça ne va pas + 3d peu plus
d'eux bien c'est à peine si tôt pas la
fille la plus de a gagné qu'une partie
contre ouvrage tu as well as rêvé de toi
c'est pas des gros scores mais c'est pas
une gaffe la partie d'aujourd'hui compte
ou pas je sais pas je la regardais la
vie m'a survolé
pas mal hein bon pourquoi pas c'était
compliqué non comme game wear s
intéressant à écouter suivant test - la
feras ton retour
oui on est sûr à d'autres choses d'ici
là les gens c'est pas le tournoi marque
en quoi vous parlez de tien schenker
2018 vous en pensez quoi
chan quoi accueillir le miracle comme
lucky merial quoi wathier bah ouais
ouais ouais je sais plus totti royal
mais non c'est pas été un tournant
marquant mais bon cette partie là où
elle était sympa n'appréciez pas non
plus non bon ok pourquoi pas si mal
quand c'est moi j'ai une espèce des
choses ça joue j'en ris dire elle est
bien comparé aux autres tu vois moi
relativisons qu'on relativise on est bon
mais écoute je te pousse ou qui on prête
à gages
je suis en train non mais je prends je
mets ça ça ça va ça rigole je vais te
suivre ses bagages je vois tu es parti
contre les mexicains quoi donc et qui
porte des chambres cloud fuyait bikey à
la chambre glacis
un mois qui est complètement nul quand
même depuis que je me connectais la
pression jean singes prévu s'était passé
avant
après je sais pas s'il albania d'or tu
vois non il est élu promouvront protège
le pion par à jouer sa vie vraiment ça a
fait psychoter c'était pas mal
lâchant allah chante la fab la chambre
que la chambre observe la france qui m'a
écrit un email allemand de s'engager
[Musique]
est ce que toi tu en grève de réception
des mails d'air france balade en forêt
dans le sport après un homme je suis
surpris mais je n'aime pas du tout le
temps je te prends ça déjà comme un spam
de bastia baratin après peut-être mais
pas sur une chaise comme télé dans le
sens où peut-être tu peux regarder ça de
chasse comme tvs qu'est-ce qu'on est
dessus parce qu'il ya là on est alors
dans un soi disant de leur bon j'ai
cliqué dessus toi parce qu'en fait il ya
sur place des états unis aussi sa
synthèse kawa d'ashland c'est chaud
ankara n'a vu que c'est tellement
l'homme en forme du moment le sang qui
va coiffer sur le poteau méchantes
langues ça va bien déjà chancelante si
tu enlèves le n est que tu enlèves le
dfc shanklin desséchante là et donc du
coup à fond et ce qu'ils ont bien fait
je sais pas on était fâché sur pièces
comme tv ils disent live n'a aucune bord
dirais moi mais non en fait déconnecté
nom est connecté ou payet le live ou pas
la main sur twitch oui on est là sur un
truc a surtout tourné l'année sur ce que
va être vérifié je suis allé j'ai joué
au début la direccte matt était très
chaud bah ouais je suis chaud parce que
je me suis fait longtemps que j'ai pas
joué et j'ai envie de faire un peu de un
peu de bus la thur ya des jours comme ça
j'ai envie de faire du bullet
donc quand j'ai envie de toi je me fais
plein je me dis pas on va demander
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait
jamais ce qu'on fait du coup j'ai
vraiment envie de faire quelque chose de
toi je prends l'initiative automatique
quoi
la chanteuse non mais du coup et c'est
marrant cette mais peut-être que mais
ils ont changé le nom du truc twitch ils
n'ont pas mis à jour et là du coup donc
le che steve et sur le site direct on a
vu par là c'est génial d'ailleurs sa
passion anonyme
c'est donc ça nos vies quoi il y aurait
un mytho qui est nouveau différent jours
plus tôt enfin julliard avant voilà quoi
fin où étais-tu coiffe un bon alors je
vous contre un colombien pas donc les
champs classes sont de retour
pariscope sonne pas je fais un truc
complètement con quoi j'ai donné
notamment heureusement qu'il n'a pas
prise je l'étais je m'en fous je monte
je mettais en fait autant fermer la dame
est sûr b3 ouais moi aussi j'ai parlé
que de chatons si vous avez des
questions sont par le chimique dont ça
va bien et vous mr qui classe néo la ola
keita tepa sa ket pas à temps il est
peut-être pour pour l'atletico ainsi
peut-être gameiro griezmann citant bien
là gameiro finalement c'est pas ça fait
pas mal pour le petit pour le petit
arsène définition un titre bah moi je
descends finir sur un titre à personne
mais bon c'est tellement de la merde ce
que je fais
on lui aussi un sapeur a alors que les
persos qui passe au guardian cuando
c'est comme un hacker qu'est ce qui se
passe ici c'est bon qu'est ce qui se
passe à 6 qu'est ce qui se passe à 6 et
recomptent chez toi c'est retourne chez
toi la cuisse qui le stream au ghana
pour l' adoption de l'amérique latine
est donc libre et mito d'un mignon qui
ne connaissait pas bitstream bas du cou
statut tu entres dans l'est les élus
c'est dans l'élite de la nasa qui
commence à connaître the place to be
quoi donc
après je connais pas il ya aussi la
chaîne youtube qui est très intéressant
alors à quand le retour des chèques à
quatre joueurs de landry qbe bah écoute
et de numériser en a marre je le relais
chauffés une partie alors là il va ce
soir sioule et sinon ce sera une fois
j'en ai marre je donne une pièce en un
coup une dame en un coup dont il n'a pas
prise après mais à je redonne du
matériel matériel l'eau je fais du kk je
suis pas du tout les deux nations
je me fais célestine est quoi c'est
horrible le double les tours c'est
horrible fab je peux rien qu'on regarde
je la fais marcher dessus
i'm échange les damas et on va jouer
cette finale
monsieur mais quand on nous dit oui il
ya plus de vivre en espagnol donc on
cherche la plus technique avec bravo à
notre stratégie
quand on est que là pour aussi faux nez
de tous les 6 heures de bon du coup on
n'a aucune valeur rien donc vous fait ce
qui marche la siph annonce ifan 1 1
qu'est ce qu'on mange ici dans un pays
laïc au maire de sarlat de loof ça j'ai
déjà mangé des crêpes de la tête du
classement à la crème de marrons s'est
complètement de la fête
je veux faire ma de la confiture débuté
là dessus puisque tu veux ou de nature
c'est grave
j'ai aussi mal que ce que je suis en
train de faire fab non monétaire plutôt
observer non j'suis pas étendu prendre
sa tour eiffel encore angers de pions
pour sauver mais je sais mais a été lent
à l'eau chaude club s'est battu et
attendrait donc états unis la centrale
de jouer comme ils sont encore en repos
non ça je lâche moi je vais jeter un
oeil
pour vous tenir au courant voilà un
envoyé spécial juste novare comment il a
perdu aujourd'hui
whatever alors je crois des états unis
on à champlan dans tête avec caruana et
gros match socar à nos jours dit merkel
petrov dont carla est très fidèle
d'autres choix de petrov
il arrive en gagnant puisque les mains
et qu'est ce que c'est et senna cas
contre champions drama cas pas du pont
pendant ce tournoi mais peut-être qu'un
jour il a tellement gagné le gp trop
convaicu
enfin je m'accroche 1 pour le moment
c'est bien ce à quoi elle mon rêve c'est
quoi la dot et ben non on l'adopté là je
pourrai pas mais baste humains 10-0 à
partir de maintenant je suis dit
j'arrête quoi hebbadj a bloqué mais ils
est utilisé beaucoup de temps pour
obtenir un truc hautement perdant mais
ici que tu as tenté ça et surtout prend
d un bon quoi est-ce qu'elle revient ce
soir dans sur le mercredi effectivement
bien répondu qu bi tube in tube i et
celle chaque choc
ces deux chercheurs qui me demandant une
vidéo spéciale clape en bas c'est à dire
s'il voulait mais je crois qu'il ya des
tutos crêpes qui serait un peu plus le
plus adapté quoi mais bon après c'est
pas très dur à faire fait un pacte
machin qu'est ce que c'est toi que tu
eric rey bon oui je sais faire la fête
malisse claque et la farine affleck
mélange pas tu penses tu des trucs
mariam attendant la vie est très dure
robe nguia banda bonga hop hop hop parce
qu'il va abandonner il va me laisser
faire
un gamin gamme attendant allez
tu as trouvé j'espère on va tourner un
jeu le faire en deux bon alors je sors
jean ferrando cieux ouais j'suis olivier
sessa dame peu transparente
oui ça existe alors qu'ils habitent dans
quel bled débit en fait bas à la
fouillouse
donc c'est pas loin de saint-etienne
c'est un petit village à la rentrée je
crois que je vais les sur paris pour l
histoire du stream plus souvent du coup
mais tu es sûr de le faire on va aller
là paritaire japon de charrier des
cheveux oui je crois que je frappe après
je sais pas combien de temps aux mangas
de la merde
pascal minne constante pour moi en 200
taquin menace des choses je n'arrive pas
à conclure
qui voyez-vous le bassin bobadilla d'or
quoi c'est vrai que c'est assez content
mais il défend paris vii lui attribuer
se mérite par savons pas d'activité
tellement moche que tu te prends pas
restant à je suis ton ne veux pas ça
sert à quoi ils me donnaient
c'est con super con comme vous
mais bon il n'a pas trop de coups à
jouer non plus une fossette mac la mano
negra bengale mais ce n'est pas comme en
géant fermé toutes ses pièces
j'ai peur c'était le party adoptif là je
n'ai absolument rien à [ __ ] je n'ai
malifaux bah oui je connais pas très
loin non mais attends ça peut être à ce
rythme on va parler des bleds à côté de
la fouillouse quand même hein ah bah si
mais ça faisait mal il faut mais c'est
pas tout à fait quoi de plus parlant
c'est un truc un peu plus en altitude
saint-genest-malifaux bastia c'est que
oui qui on parle
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
c'est intéressant c'est drôle du col du
grand bois
ah les femmes j'adapte je suis chaud
femmes si si si si revient à l'adresse
de m
christian il est parti il est parti
quelque part c'est une semi adoption l
adoption et des christian les a pas
passé par l'espanyol 2-1 ap la
colombienne shakira shakira black
boliviano à l'espagnol à la caste yann
perreau noab la jeter l'anathème
il me prouver quattro state en est ainsi
c'est bessines quoi
omer va comme elle à damas
s'il fabián leamy chef ski une grande
des masses trop mastro grande masquer
une masse trop toujours sa patte du
number and gaubert robert de pseudo que
dégage ce à cause de petits pions allant
de 6 il devrait pas l'avoir il aurait pu
s'en débarrasser à mainte et mainte
reprise et d'un point à 5 vont se voir
carrément rien aujourd'hui bon mais
qu'on regarde est complètement nul
bon chez nous de la pédagogie un petit
peu non mais là glissera prochain de sa
femme mon pote pédagogie pour cette
partie on comprend ici c'est très
pédagogique
la pédagogie prenait les pièces en un
les mecs très importante pour les pièces
en main quand vous donnez une tour en 1
prenez la cote très très pédagogique ça
d'un cran dès 8 da pédagogique à dieu de
la vraie pédagogie boum ça c'est
pédagogique g5
j'arrive quatre ans du coup un canal
maroc hors jeu est une semaine je pars
demain je reviens vendredi prochain
c'est rapide qu'un tournoi c'est bien le
reste nous serons très plaisir ils ont
raison de faire les tours à court comme
ça c'est bien ben quoi s'attendre à
rallonge là avec eux quelques jours de
repos je sais pas d'un bon ok je peux
comprendre un jour de repos des fois
pourquoi pas bah non non non jamais donc
de plus je peux le comprendre mais tu
peux le comprendre il fat et
contrebandiers la pac et trois jours de
repos avant un tournoi ça va tu tolère
tu veux dire comme un jour pourquoi pas
un jour ça mais bon moment se débine
non mais tu as raison que des coureurs
de marathon quoi ah mais c'est
extrêmement tu fais un marathon dans
leur peau va je peux comprendre mais
quand tu joues ton tennis français un
grand chelem un jour de repos sur deux
pourquoi pas encore s'il pleut pas mais
quand tu fais un tournoi avec les
matches en trois sets ne parte masters
1000 ou quoi tu joues tous les jours
mais c'est moins éprouvant que les
échappements
oui bah du coup c'est voilà c'est ça la
conclusion c'est que bah il me serait en
vie il est moins éprouvant que 80 des
cochers aboutir matière c'est très très
éprouvant durant deux minutes sur toi
regardez d'ailleurs c'est encore plus
éprouvant à regarder qu'à jouer des
saucisses et trenton moi je prends de
l'espace de partout enfin toujours selon
chidi et oui comme bobby fisher ben je
suis un genre de bobby fischer un
quelque part mais ce que tu t'es pas
over extended ne peux non je suis dit
non c'est fantastique comme réponse
tarde que complètement oui mais moi je
te dis non je te demandais juste je pose
des questions naïves ait fait le
candidat parti a écrit candide c'est pas
la question qu'on se pose voltaire la
culture dans ta gueule fable c'est beau
parce que je dois en parler enfin je me
suis offert extended je sais pas bastien
rover extended sera attention le pion
été très l'ouvreur extended kouagou me
dégage tellement ils se sont dit je te
manger à l'e3 poison moi je suis de la
merde là pour vous quand bien même si
place un camp bien même faut le savoir
je me développe enfin
dégage le chat ne parle plus trop sur
l'a6 illizi coûte pas je peux s'ils sont
la petite son bar et enfin parmi son
love 142 preuve en chiffres c'est le
départ contre la loire forcément
au-dessus
et aussi c'est un chiffre de lost donc
vos pubs le monde un chiffre de 6 de
lost à l'alena héros de la journée
donner un certain 4 8 15 16 23 42 donc
doublement important dans sa 43ème place
dans le dernier carré et donc tu peux
repartir mais que se connecter plus tu
n'es pas dans 28 états en chiffres de la
cellule très attention moi je fais je
vous prends des cas tfc quand j'annonce
les tontons fin fond je gagne ce
cavalier
bon il ne laisse pas faire bon moi j'ai
dû bouffer sa merde je suis très bien en
fait enfin consolide de l'accord de fou
quand on demande à nos six échecs on
sait pas pourquoi
alain je vais jouer les foudres dommage
j'avais calculé dan cavalli des six
dames celle ci s'est vu infliger pas
compris qu'il a une pièce en un coup en
fait les deux sens encore quoi non mais
des fois c'est déstabilisant quand les
mecs te donne une pièce en un coup pas
de chance enfin toi ça déstabilise pas
qu'on les mecs fait que de la buba
écoute quand il joue comme ça à régir le
premier coup d'essai 10 ans tu calcules
un truc est juste à tata même pas le
temps d'ajuster quoi j'aime bien
déstabiliser comme ça j'arrête à dire
n'ai fait que les primes ou six joutes
de mer choix qui veulent bouffer des
pièces toute ombre des pillages ridicule
dépenses
écoute attention à te donne je suis pas
si j'aurai besoin de faire les pieds de
ridicule là parce que madame beckham
qu'est-ce que je suis con [ __ ] des
couilles bon font mal assez violent
c'est violent d'être aussi con quand
même un mini votre porte vous mettez en
place on sait ce que tu vaux rien ouais
c'est pas gagné quoi faut pas crier
victoire ou pas vendre la peau de l'ours
et j'ai crié crié et j'ai pleuré c'est
aline elle revient pour qu'elle
reviendrait à beaubien justice est très
déstabilisée en fait je suis
complètement déstabilisé
bon je crois que j'étais très énervé
mais tu peut l'adopter du jeu sans les
options possibles
peut-être mettre la pression bah je sais
pas c'est pas toujours évident d'adopter
mettez à mi chemin et le mec je crois
qu'il pétait les plombs tirés des primes
pourri mais il peut se faire adopter
il perd un peu dans ce principe là
j'espérais tu vas fin fou c'est vrai que
ce que vous êtes un petit sous mon nom
je m'entraîne aussi bien petit sou mais
malheureusement il arrêter quoi 6 0 il a
senti l'adoption était proche d'être
adoptée quand même la moitié d'opter
qu'en 2007
du coup on peut pas notre shot de on
peut pas importer des gif ou quoi dans
l'autre match il faut faire de
l'ingérence dans les taux de contraste
pas de chance fab
alors faut que je fasse gaffe quand même
ce que lui mais un peu plus malin que le
précédent
[ __ ] ça ne m'y attendais pas du tout
il m'a complètement dérouté quoi ton
égyptien je sais pas qui c'est mais il
m'a complètement mis en perce pas
franchement père a joué une finale je
m'en fous complètement
j'ai absolument rien à [ __ ] des pions
double avec à sa tête passe juste à
poznan ouverte quoi bon il ya plus de
tours c'est pas grave je serai pas un du
tout voilà
ils étaient cinq chier c'est foutu
c'est plein c'est un objectif
d'extinction d'accord d'accord on te
conseille de jouer en vrac hull et
s'allume avec ce qui est drôle 30 et non
sur fois la cession de quatre échecs en
team psychiatre oui pourquoi pas espérer
conclut que c'est sûr et théâtre
bailly donne pas de romagny il est où le
suricate ses peintures discorde
donc il ya une question section 100
d'avancé sur iker
enfin la question c'est chaud c'est
chaud femmes
ces chaudes a reperdu ça j'ai parié gros
bosseur un une partie double échec à 4
en double
mais pourquoi pas mais ça me demandent
de changer le mais on peut citer comme
c'était chiant pointu puzenat est un peu
on peut pour blitz et pour une fois que
je suis pro vie de ses réponses il sauve
toi mais des pls muscles
non mais je m'amuse n'avait su ce que
les mecs se barrent pas les charges de
mecs je suis en train de l'adopter ils
se barrent la ces mecs là ce bar bon ben
je suis juste quand un gm coiffard ça
fait chier quoi jeter en train d'adopter
des mais complètement nul
que ce soit en vue j'ai pas envie du
régime ça fait chier vision galluzzi en
quoi mes joues pas si mal je passe mon
heureusement que tu me le dis quoi parce
que là on s'en rend pas trop compte pour
le monsieur approbation on a du mal à
s'en rendre compte nous
c'était peut-être coin ça
ah [ __ ] pas de chance mais j'ai super
mal en plus c'est vrai j'ai senti je
fais un truc qu'on cale idiot 5
attention sachant que tu pas ça très
intelligent ce que je fais je sens que
ce mal aujourd'hui je vois pas de
tactique je vois rien c'est horrible je
sens que je vois rien je suis super man
direct pas quant à eux 4 avril à peu
faire j'ai appris la danse à d'autres
juste ouvrir jeudi un pion joue je m'en
fous mais je pense que tu vois pas ce
que la en fait une est le cavalier e cat
et peut-être je survis ça en fait nous
avons passé du bullet danny danon tout
peut arriver c'est qu'on est stratégique
ce cas non plus la vie tenté un petit
merguez ou jamais
mais très bien mais le film ne tourne
pas merci merci merci je connais bien
sympa quoi ce film j'ai bien vu que le
tournage soit déploient tout univers des
niveaux de personnes tout ça c'était
cool quoi tout ça n'est pas de découvrir
budapest une bien belle ville quoi
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on fait le stage
là-bas sans le tournoi je pense pas que
j'aurais eu cette idée
bon allez m'a pas l'air impressionnant
12 bien fait qu'alexis après c'est connu
fabre normalement oui mais bon je suis
pas sûr que
raille la faune machin quand bien même
on sait pas si grave
c'est pas si grave fable
très bizarrement en fait j'aime bien
joli petit avec une qualité de moins
enfin j'aime bien ce rapport au matériel
d'après m c'est une fiction c'est pas
donc le reportage on fait attention
c'est un documentaire
donc je veux dire non mais y'a des trucs
intéressants
tu as raison mais sylvie c'est dans la
tête d'un joueur avec la pression des
coachs et c'est à ces choses qui peuvent
exister mais aussi 500 films ou font
défaut à grossir les traits pour toi tu
vas rentrer ça aussi accessible au grand
public
ce n'est pas un film spécialement pour
les joueurs d'échecs enfin c'est pas
contre non plus quand même des charges
et coûts très bien le voir mais c'est
aussi donc destiné à n'importe qui donc
voilà il faut aussi des fois grossir le
trait ghetto quoi et je dois dire tu as
tu eu vent tournera falla c'est une
bande de jeunes un bon montant des
dégâts quand la petite vingtaine donc à
cet âge là tu constates partir de chez
toi tu es content de plus en plus sur le
foot après tu vois l'élite mondiale car
obscènes ou quoi elle va pas voir même
train de vie l'élite de l'élite des
échecs
voilà la nation après il ya tout ce
travail de recherche pour le film qu'on
sépare l'échec de variants de trucs
comme ça
les positions qui a dans le sait dans le
film soit c'est travailler c'est pas
n'importe quoi même la partie de fin la
combinaison elle et elle marche
c'est ce oui non en fait c'est vrai mais
du coup l'autre mais en gros il faut pas
que se dire que c'est comme ça chaque
tournoi avec une tresse a même plutôt
l'inversé
mais bon on va très bien et a pu en tout
cas c'est cool c'est le but étant bien
entendu de faire un coup d'oeil un peu
publicité notre âme en notre jeu
dépoussiérer un peu tout ça ben c'est
pas mal a les boules dégage
choquant bref s'être dégage alors où tu
vas mon ami ou mouton faits appuient pas
convaincu de sa chevauchée un nom pas
bon que d'accrocher sa chaîne non non
achevé hier alors attends on est proche
de 2007
c'est pas le moment de craquer c'est
vraiment ce que je suis complètement
explosé je t'assure que je vois rien
baissées et visages mêmes trucs des fois
où je vois rien en fait ce serait très
bien et je sais pas pourquoi ce que je
vois vraiment rien je t'assure que ces
jeunes qui sont super nul parce que je
vois rien il est le seul truc que je
vois il les voit pas quoi pas pour le
moment ça peut s'arrêter à tout moment
là la fois que ça m'a fait ça je veux
contenu baume après ça il même avoir eu
ma vie trop froid ni quoi je en train de
faire de la 4g / d'un procès des tours à
la chance sur s 4g ou c5 et chaque
peut-être ou pas voilées on va pas jouer
au con championnat mais j'ose y aura des
gages le jour à 6,13 utilement roues
très bien que les françaises grande
avance à 6
c'est fantastique j'ai coincé genre fait
exploser du fait que de la merde mais je
sais pas quoi te dis que tu fais de la
merde ça marche mais je faisais le soir
aussi je crois que j'ai gagné 12 parties
dessus de promotion je vais me coucher
comme je trouve à tillé j'ai composé les
rangées l'accent sur n'importe quoi et
presque pas de chance quoi parce que
revient la tâche qu'on va j'ai mal à la
gorge et c'est ça que jamais ça a
commencé quand balle et quelques jours
ou semaines
néji par nature je parle je suis pas je
pars pas ma voix j'ai pas mal tout le
temps mais dès que je déguste un peu de
salive ou quoi je sais pas très chiant
je vous renvoie tout ça parce que c'est
peut être un rhume des foins conneries
comme ça pendant que je me dis mais
rhume des foins je crois que c'est hyper
violent j'ai plus de temps là
malheureusement femmes
[Musique]
ça va faire une nouvelle adoption finale
il m'a dit que des coups d'oeil sous peu
[Musique]
c'était parce que
c'est un cas un peu plus de temps
j'aurais arnaquer si la normale c'était
horrible
car s'il fait d'armes au même moment pas
bon c'est n'importe quoi c'est vrai que
j'ai passé tant parce que le vin que ce
sera quand c'est finalement oui c'est
pas sûr que le pas tant que musée m'a
formé et pas top et je comprends pas
comment je vais me faire dézinguer quoi
mais qu'est pas ouf
j'aime boire un truc du miel quoi votre
recette miracle bon avec du miel par
annonce vous souhaite un peu la gorge
est de lier nasa mamitiana ce papy
grenet c mami li na l'a construit quand
tu fais mieux blood tout simplement ou
maintenant elle fait miel l'emia les
avec à leur âge ou du gingembre
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont l'impression
semmam il y en a même un qui va bientôt
rentrer d'ailleurs arnaud qu'aimer c'est
pas un génie quand même en face la femme
dont on n'a jamais dit ça n'a jamais été
génial deux parties devant comme c'est
bien de la merde
bon
bon je laisse tomber ont été dissoutes
le chou transparent c'est pas comme ça
d'une tour à halle et votre angoisse on
sait très bien
sinon les lego là le dessin me super
diviser tout est super génial comme un
fantastique façon tatin j'ai regardé le
dessin animé dégâts [ __ ] quand le
joker et tout ça avec batman
ouais je sais que je vous aurais dit que
c'était pas si les bisons pas assez des
villes mais que ça peut se regarder
c'est génial je viens tous les méchants
de tout partout de tout le monde qui
sont là bas tout le monde sort on est
traité comme tout j'aurais pu prendre
c'est fait c'est fait
bon moi je suis allé voir avengers mais
c'est pas mal
au fils aîné mais fin mai quand même
bien non mais ce qui est génial avec les
lego complètement coin moi c'est comme
une chanson super con quoi tout est
super génial comme super heureux chand
size
c'était tout est super génial
automatiquement belga les recrutements
de personnel hautement te fixes et puis
moi je crois et je sais de ferrié
j'allais faire un échec théoriquement je
peux prendre un café se faire enfermer
la tour
merde cette course de vitesse un truc
j'ai fait assez de temps
non non non j'ai déjà pris la dalle
dalle mate et quoi même les super nul
c'est horrible de géotechnique
défaillant c'est tellement ça ou alors
t'es whisky mais l on me propose ccaf
quand même l'alcool n'aurait on pas très
bon quand tu veux on va faire des
défenses immunitaires
avec ce midi qui est trop de trop
d'analgésiques sont 25 mai s'est glissé
des abrutis cd rom aux abrutis avengers
et bah non c'est le groupe avec captain
america hulk thor spider man il ya des
gardiens à galaxies il ya a vu le
gardien la galaxie
quand il s'appelle sujet ni un docteur
strange page contenus sont partout des
black panthers n'ont ils sont au ps ça
tout cela mais avec une connection des
cailloux et si les a tous vous êtes très
très fort ce serait intéressant comme
production mais un ajout de l'appel des
pierres d'infinité pour ça que j'aime ça
infinity ward
enfin moi je suis le nom du film
et oui on ne me croit que la cité iron
man j'ai mes repères
ouais bon chrono de froid devrait pas
traîner
enfin ça se regarde quand même c'est
plus du côté mais bon toujours si en
fait ces films détente quoi ça va [ __ ]
cherchent pas activement experts non
plus évidemment comment générer adam
qu'un abruti la [ __ ] mais en film de
super héros mais j'avais quand même
vraiment adoré la trilogie batman de
nolan
maintenant on avait adoré ce très jeune
il était au-dessus est du coup si vous
avez aimé ça il vous n'êtes pas encore
regardé ce ferry netflix daredevil sur
trois se sont d'ailleurs je trouve van
der wiel van nhon d'art des villes
étapes jamais regardé comme ça
n'explique ce et quand j'ai et que tu as
bien aimé à la trilogie batman c'est
bien la fin c'est ok ça mais qu il est
bon quoi évidemment mais c'est pas aux
caisses comme comme la trilogie cossu à
batman est fort mais il n'a pas des
super pouvoirs débile ou chez paco fin
ses bienfaits de la construction des
personnages machine à spams à la fois
que c'était le fait qu'avec sol puisque
arrêtera assez fort quoi évidemment
c'est encore une fois c'est un
documentaire assez naïve et aveugle ce
baume sur 6 ha mais non abonnés pour moi
c'était mon préféré parce que depuis
qu'ils ont fait aux défendeurs avec duke
edge il ya signé depuis nicheurs j'ai
regardé ma moto qu'il faut avoir vu déjà
des trucs énormes et oui non ça c'est
pas et jessica jones ce qu'il ya des
gens qui ont beaucoup aimé bon façon
j'ai tout regardé ça va je
je vérifie ce sujet le moi et mes mails
en tout cas mon combat c'était
clairement daredevil et la saison -
jusqu'à jones après l'actrice est très
mignonne oui bah je l'avais vu dans
batman bane je crois que c'est la copine
de jesse pinkman qui vendent leur dose
je crois que c'est la même si je me
trompe pas c'est quelque chose à
annoncer qu'elle changeait excuse moi là
je suis en mode
l'abruti total je crois qu'il avait
réduit l'an passé les nobles de vieilles
rb6 la chance je vais arriver
d'ouverture alors gones et icône est
pourri après ils connaissent la théorie
du coup ça ils aiment bien aussi je
pense
bon jeu que capa en dix minutes
j'espère qu'on pourra dire le live mais
tu vas tu voir le match ouais soutenu m
mais sur un truc qui m'a étonné que
terme étant de foot en fait bon vous
même c'est pas un reproche à la fin
pourquoi pas tu vois non mais quelque
part ça peut les sous-estimer ce fait
foot ça arrive avec bof un peu toi mais
c'est un beau sport mais bon après faut
dire que moi je suis né dans la ville
région c'est important enfin bon c'est
très courant que tout le monde va au
stade tu as une sorte de transmission de
père en fils on te parle des matchs de
l'époque machin que j'ai jamais vécue et
bouger c'est toute cette époque là alors
que j'avais vu le match en entier quoi
j'ai vu des cassettes vidéo des extraits
des machins je me suis dit je garde qui
joue les 70 et je sais pas ça c'est
spécial donc j'aime bien le jeu j'aime
bien l'histoire du jeu je connais dans
cette coupe du monde fait du coup je me
suis intéressé à tout ça n'est donc pas
juste dans le sens d'aller au stade
duels et insulté l'arbitré les joueurs
adverses bien de choucas verticaux
chouder géant vient l'occasion avant la
chance de parler avec on va entrer leur
[ __ ] que tu vas comprendre des trucs
comme emplacement n'est pas possible je
perde cette finale quand même le
craquage quoi aller mais j'ai un peu
craqué que j'aurais vraiment pu faire
2007 ce soir ouais bon que ce sont les
centraux faudra stopper l'hémorragie si
tu vois plus rien plus loin que le mal
est là c'est que tu peux tu peux
toujours faire tomber la perdre contre
lui quand même ça fait peur
battu par arrêt catherine denis gadoury
joie juste nous deux quatre et demi 4 2
me contre 1 est aussi nul ça fait quand
même peur pas la rallonge aurait dû
l'adopter du juste dit m attend ses
limites way avait pour avoir un truc
mais qui était vraiment faible
ouais mais là c'est pas avant la joue
contre avec moins bien classés qui va
jouer mieux que le précédent mais pas la
bonne variante 1
très vite j'ai déjà joué non plus il
monte on va t'il pas si nul mais ce que
je sais dit j'étais sûr enfin allumés
que jouer avant c'est un cadeau quoi
mais bon je n'étais pas habitué à ça
en fait il est pas si minime soit il ya
assez vieux clocher se souriaient de
valeur en fait non et et je pas trop ma
faim car il passe pas trop mal ces
pièces tous âges
enfin je sais pas 30 actif avec deux ou
trois parties clean mais je n'avais pas
à classer comme mec nul donc petit à me
faire changer la ville pour l'instant
même très envie de le classer dans les
menus bon il a peut-être fait flinguer
tout cela une peau de blizzard n'a même
pas vu si la glace et dans les mecs pas
très fort tactiquement on a eu envie de
leur donner des pions
mais c'est ce que j'adore dans mes
billets à quel point je prends les mecs
pour des abrutis c'est génial
ma chambre mais pas longtemps un mec qui
mixe c'est ce qu'ils aient l'esprit
léger le succès de mes strips de prendre
pour des cons merris très drôle ben je
sais pas alors les gens pouvaient vous
pouvez le dire dans le chat comme
d'autres qui me prend 1,5 g passe pas
clair encore sur le matos quoi y avait 8
ans prise et elle est très grave a tué 3
2 dans sa vallée oui enfin je réponds
oui mais non mais il avait un moment
facile famille bicois demi je les classe
et un joueur bon ok bon non je suis pas
signer là bon là pour le coup et
vendredi à shanghai
je pense que tu as joué le style de
trucs oui qu'on croit rien fait a choisi
c'était un mec est cassé les pièces pour
josi il comprenait le plastron des
pièces
quand je dis finalisé pas de fautes
grossières non seulement ces trucs-là
stratégique on m'a suggéré gemmill
banias d'orge et me lâcher je les chante
la coiffe donc si vous repas si je suis
d'attaqué c'est très bien écrit elle me
vouvoie nourris mais c'est un jeu où
[Musique]
jamais un jeu que je ne me tutoie pas
quoi faire tuer tuer les inférieurs à
moi tu tu veux vous attend non c'est un
bleu passer d'un jeu moralement le
tutoie que je sache ou témoin n'a mais
quand elle met crème voit des gens en
rupture avec celle qui disait quick
évitons mépris est génial non mais
j'adore mais je méprise complètement qua
non mais j'adore v6 et c'est une de mes
phrases
enfin je dis pas souvent en stream mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire tu es nul
jce à un élève hier enfin google juifs
avant tout adversaire m jusqu'à preuve
du contraire il ne s'est pas joué mon
match prouve que tu sais jouer pour le
moment où tu t'assures face de lui
jusqu'à preuve du contraire tu es nul
quoi j'adore cette phrase mais du coup
faut pas lui faciliter la tâche pour
prouver qu'il est pas nul ah non je dis
tu te prend vertement pour un con tu ta
et si tu voyais devant condescendant
quoi jusqu'à preuve du contraire avec le
cépage mais bon après si c'est jouer tu
avis quoi fin tu te débrouilles maps
qu'ils un complexe d'infériorité
puisqu'ils je compte des mecs et 300
points de plus et il est mieux dans
toutes les parties et il fait des nuls
tu vois ta job parce qu'il naccepte nul
ou non mais parce que vraiment donné au
lieu de tuer il a peur que oui peut-être
mais aguilera en finale le factuel il
dit ok le mec doit bien être meilleur
que moi dans un secteur du vieux blaye
les mines ils ont jusqu'à preuve du
contraire enfin j'aurai une meilleure
position tu l'a dominé de partout
jusqu'à preuve du contraire que plus
fort que moi je suis une mère en rien
les mairies
pas de muscles mais je m'attends à jouer
en 3d serait pas ce qui compte c'est que
qu'est ce que je demande non mais si
content quand même joué beaucoup merde
[ __ ] ce soit de la partie en face si
je veux les meilleurs coups on s'en fout
quoi ça votre carte c'est la position du
new york la position cité mijoter mieux
enfin tu commences par g4 c'était ça je
les alpes et avantages certains
la paire à quezon missclick de merde
n'auriez pas de tourner à ce soir le
parti comme ça j'aurais dû échanger les
dames quoi
juste rien quoi sourire
saint-simon mystique qui me coûte la
partie c'est horrible
alors que j'étais vraiment pas loin dès
à hesdin branché 5 depuis tout à l'heure
de voir venir mais après cela n'a plus
de gaz
pas de chance
chargé 5 c'était mieux
ce sera ma dernière partie que je
reviens tu parles sans le sou tout
attention de la santé doit une arme en
une heure trente mille 30
mesbah avant le foot un habitant
ok ça va pas quand je commence à perdre
des positions comme ça c'est mauvais si
c'est mauvais signe de perdre est partie
comme sa femme ouais ne se sont pas rués
pour ce boxeur encore perdu mais ils
tendent et eu peu de partout péniche ans
rien ce qui fait en fait ça m'énerve
belle victoire 6 1 [ __ ] je les ai vus
depuis tout à l'heure
finalement à force de tenter de faire
albania nord amérique s est supérieure
ou de perdre contre cette action
ouais je file évasif il un film bat plus
tard bonne soirée à tous allez l'om et
on se tient au jus on sur l'abandon sur
youtube
ouais merci bâton dont ses parents et
les banou elle ne voit pas mais biseau
chat je suis la femme
allez on va se concentrer les mecs c'est
super con les particules perdu quand
même
c'est d'ailleurs ce que ce mec est plus
tactique beaucoup moins stratégiques
iris voit pas grand chose j'ai
l'impression qu'il me tendait cheapos de
partout à reculer
enfin
ok on n'a rien et on est mal autant
on va la perdre aussi
qu'elle m'a poussé le pion
ah ouais j'ai d'échangés aïe aïe aïe
bah c'est horrible on repère toutefois
aulas la dame j'ai quatre échecs
je n'ai pas pris move ont récupéré la
dame mais ça craint quoi un tour perdu
mais je veux plus voir plus grand chose
mais kluba 3 0 avec des positions
calamiteuse un tel truc avec la dame de
plus ce qu'ils étaient quand même tendu
et là je commence à faire n'importe quoi
by adam f 3 ar non mais ok là c'est la
cata trop de fatigue
en quel sens on fait ça c'est qu'on a
sauvés mais j'ai perdu trop de temps
trop de temps de perdu bon la position
n'est pas est pas si mauvaise boum
il pouvait faire cavalier prendre j'ai
peut-être des tactiques cépages pas sûr
que ça ait marché
allez faut qu'on continue
qu'est-ce qui fait
on va les changer
3 c'est de la merde donc elle à ce qu'il
est en train de faire c'est horrible
moi aussi
bah je vais faire tour 3 évidemment
quelle horreur
ce serait pas la mecque la tour 3
jeune importe quoi mais bon j'aurais dû
avoir la tour aux trois déjà pour avoir
des tactiques
ah là là je vais pas mettre la tour e
évidemment à je fais de la merde j'ai
peur de relarguer tous mes points voire
plus je sens que je suis plus à un jeu
plus de temps de plus tous dedans
ok g g 7
ok c'est rien tout ça
ces semis dangereux mais ça va il joue
très tactique mais pas bien du tout pour
les pièger pour l'attack mais il voit
pas forcément grand chose non plus
qui va lui rendre le pion par lui donner
le plus en plus tôt
le problème c'est que cette position est
vraiment pas saine
pas faire grand chose avec les blancs
c'est une horreur c'est débile comme on
joue c'est tellement con certaines
parties ça affreux s'était tapé ça
mhadjou hermé parti comme c'est parti
je suis complètement perdant
c'est affligeant
s'étant bien que mal débuté
mam au quai
complètement débile mais la parade de la
finale patrick seale nous rase des
points puis ça chaque fois ok il tente
et b4 direct pour tenter le piège on va
sortir la dame en prenant ces 3
et ça va aller
quel échange petit à petit les pièces
qui a percé plus rien maintenant sur les
bon ok allez faut remarquer font
remarquer tout de suite
allez hop hop hop
ainsi d'attaquer droit à n'y a pas y'a
pas froid cette gtx
je suis idiot
car je vais prendre les faire d'un match
5 ok sur g6v d'un match si c'est sûr qu
on prend jeu damage sept matches ok ça
ça doit le faire ok c'est cool
allez allez les mecs on continue
ramener le calme et par ici prendre
prendre d'un match 4 samedi quatre
échecs mettre le fou en d6
peut-être pas mal je sais faire qu'à
l'âge de damas trois auxquels à damas
trois échecs et dame prend arias pas
d'un prof de maths
quelle horreur 1 je vais ramener et de
fer d'un échec d'un échec là mais chaque
tête ont fait nul on va faire un nul on
n'a pas trouvé mieux peut-être commencer
par des cinq à la sphère des cinq
maintenant c'est cool on prendre
l'espace dont qui veut récupérer des
cases mais c'est pas grave on s'en fout
on va pousser comme des brutes on gagne
à kas g5 le fou c'est pas grave mais
trois ans consolide
si une tour en quatre c'est un peu tendu
ça c'est chiant
ça c'est très chiant manqué en récupère
ça ici on récupère salah jeu parce que
ça donne
poussé j'ai monté le roi
à protéger
je poussais
[Musique]
ok ok commandes
c'était chaud c'est pour le manque de
commentaire
enfin des gens qui sont partis voir le
match aussi j'imagine aller et il faut
bouger car sinon ce petit intermédiaire
fait mal j'ai pas vu le pion à 7
ça fait très mal
tatoué la finale à yalta rally qui tombe
à la fin et on perd quelle horreur my
eyes manque un peu de vitesse
ridicule
ridicule de la merde je pousse fallait
pas pousser fait j'ai joué trois très
mal joué c'est ça je prends ma place non
j'avais du cavalier c'est 7 à la fin
j'imagine c'est un des six dames à 5
reste pas très bien joué je sais pas je
vais essayer de placer b6 enfin de
vendre pour lui enfermé sa tour ce que
j'ai fait maintenant et la torah plus de
cases
tu vas prendre là et on va prendre là ok
nickel la chance allez on en voit on
gratte le pion
bon je vais assez vite on lui met un
petit fou b4 je n'ai pas le temps lui
mettre du fougueux 4 sur al iman du fou
b4 avant ma petite finale elle va être
sympa tosh qui est chiant pas trop
comment je joue
je suis pas très efficace là j'ai perdu
beaucoup de temps
j'ai pas testé est du tout et on les
enferme son cavalier quand même
il va aller courir après ce pion
xi a pas être si simple on a plus de
temps
c'est un cavalier 6 à yahvé curieuse ces
cercles aurait pu sauver la nulle quelle
horreur quelle horreur
je fais n'importe quoi je fais n'importe
quoi
à
c'est bien dommage
ça allait plus ou moins nickel à gratin
option mais bon il va me jouer autant il
veut jouer à la pendule à chaque fois un
an
c'est un peu là que le bât blesse
il n'y a pas de maths dégage on est
revenu à égalité 1 de basile mené trois
points je pas trop où on a gratté nos
points mais çà et là on a pris des
points
on a réussi à revenir
au caire à écouter
j'aurais dû mettre le foie en c5 dommage
le matin f6 du coup
c'est ce qui est promis 5 faire [ __ ]
en e2 pas assez risqué à qui prend à 7
c'est hyper dangereux
la sermat et
comme des merdes
bach avec le roi mais savait sa c5
direct c'est tellement mal joué camatte
en un pour lui donc et il peut faire
dame français
je suis pas sûr de bien jouer là je ne
suis pas sûr du tout de bien jouer
donc on menace ça il va prendre là qui
aiment pas de problème
ok car 5 il doit avoir un problème avec
le cavalier a attaqué le fou ni call
allez faut lui faire mal
je vais faire mal avec une ce qu'en
disent allez qui démarre mieux que les
autres
enfin gagner une finale avec un pion de
plus avec les bras si on a réussi à
jouer vite il faut en profiter
ok cette pièce gratos à prendre l'option
on va venir là on va prendre la pièce
est ok saillon lui enfin fait mal
je suis pas sûr de bien jouer elle a une
nouvelle fois
mais plutôt sur deûle inverse enfin bon
comprendre le contrôle un peu de la case
2,5 passes c'est pas bon non plus assez
mauvais ça
c'est une horreur allons mettre la tour
en d3 ont pas trop ce qui fait
c'est d'échanger les dames je suis de la
merde total heureusement saluant ferme
cinq tours et ça va
bon je vais essayer d'y aller à la
brutale
c'est complètement enfin je me fais
maths et en un comme une merde non mais
c'est grave
j'avais dû qu'à faire car lycées 6
prendre le pion à 5 l'automate de de
merde
quelle horreur cet automate quoi affreux
affreux
rien de nouveau bien c'est un peu les
montagnes russes c'est parti bon
goûté à ça c'est complètement idiot mais
bon ça va j'ai des échecs qui me sauve
à
ok je peux prendre ici on ici ok changer
ça venir là j'ai tout reprend le 4 quel
dommage
prieto repenser syst
[Musique]
je suis très très mal
bon
à
à quelle horreur bon il est 21h30 c'est
la dernière mais vraiment à freud a
reperdu la précédente
là on aurait pu faire beaucoup mieux
contre cet adversaire 1 on pourrait être
beaucoup mieux que ce que l'omb petit
craquage non celle là bas je vois plus
rien gros coup de pompe
gros coup de fatigue
mais ça aurait pu être beaucoup une
pareille à poupre en f3 et b6 mais je
vois plus rien c'est fini dames 17 et
il a cette envie ou pas
on a envie d'action complètement pourri
mais pas d'abandon pour le moment
on va bloquer l'avancée des pions
moi j'veux pas sûr que ce soit très
malin ce qu'il fasse
non qu ils avaient tombé la dernière est
malheureusement fini à 26 5 ans dans les
puits monte à 27
ok il aurait fallu être un peu plus en
forme un peu moins fatiguer un peu plus
encore un peu plus chaud et mais bon
c'était sympa quand même
merci les mecs d'avoir suivi et je vous
dis et je vous dire la prochaine j'aurai
peut-être un petit stream sur la chaîne
youtube ce week end à voir merci d'avoir
suivi s'est écoulé désolé de parapher
ciao ciao